von hebel
[Musique]
les choses devraient bien pas trop
fatigué vous avez donné combien de
pouvoir monsieur la voix la messe mais
vous donner car si vous avez combien
combien de temps elle a une tonne le top
5 français ça fait ça ferait normalement
du stand pour voir oui dodu et donc là
en définitive vous deviez avoir 12
franck doudet u20 en france a offert 800
802 pouvoir voilà c'est ça ces douze
france boulay qui sont non l'allemand
d'office afin d'offrir édition d'office
qui n'en ont pas mangées rythme le soir
la patronne c'est au bureau à gaza
monsieur qu'est ce que vous en pensez
que se pourvoirait ce qu'est ce que la
famille c'est normal mais c'est normal
pour le travail qu'il fait de boire un
café à 12h30 pour moi par contre je
trouve pas normal ou normal c'est dans
les quartiers qu'il n'est pas en fixer
comme nous alors moi je trouve ça bien
cette fois pour cela c'est inadmissible
de voir des membres des choses pareilles
je parle pour sa part d'une femme
travaille là dedans mais je trouve ça
vous êtes obligés à tendre la main pour
pour manger la troupe de soir si haut si
vite si la personne
[Musique]
généralement au comptoir le service non
compris ou laissée à l'appréciation de
la clientèle
[Musique]
ouais
alors lorsque l'on règle sa consommation
doit-on laisser quelque chose aux
garçons oui et c'est normal dans la
mesure où tout service mérite un salaire
et par conséquent on laisse entrevoir
pour rémunérer le service a été rendu
pour remercier la façon dont il a été
rendu mais encore faut-il s'entendre sur
le sens du mot pour boire à l'origine il
ya de cela plusieurs siècles le power
c'est est ce que les seules seigneur à
la personne qui leur ont rendu service
pour boire à sa santé
aujourd'hui il est plus question que les
garçons de café par exemple utilise tout
ce qu'on leur laisse pour boire des
consommations d'abord parce que la ligue
en quelques clics interviendrait ensuite
parce que l'époux malheureux ne pourrait
pas résister en fait il faut distinguer
endroit entre le service et le pourboire
ce sont des choses aussi différentes que
les armes ou les acomptes par exemple
mais que tout le monde mélange en fait
le service est quelque chose qui est
toujours obligatoire
c'est une somme qui est tu perds le
client tandis que le pourboire lui n'est
jamais obligatoire garçon s'il vous
plaît un garçon est ce que ici à ce bar
est ce que ici le pourboire est
obligatoire
et le service puisque c'est notre salle
est énorme et le service laissée à
l'appréciation des clientes à l'idée
quand même obligatoire oui sinon n'a
rien à manger puisque c'est uniquement
au tir
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
expression laissée à l'appréciation des
clientèles ci n'est pas laissée à
l'appréciation des clientèles en dépit
du déficit obligatoires pourquoi laisser
l'application j'ai défini où vous voulez
si l'aînée qui tous les sports s'il veut
pas vous laisser vous pouvez rien faire
pour aller chercher la monnaie dans sa
poche quel est le truc de consommation
sur internet fai vous avez laissé
combien de services de services ou de
pourboire de pourvoir à l'offre service
service et donc c'est obligatoire en
principe oui j'ai passé obligatoire si
le service obligatoire
oui et pour voir
pour voir c'est pareil c'est pour voir
service alors stoppé y atteler en
principe n'est pas obligatoire ni valeo
est partie à l'appréciation des
clientèles sont d'ailleurs obligatoire
ou facultatif c'est pas que tati
financier pas obligatoire ajoutez à cela
que très souvent le consommateur une
espèce de peur de paraître pingre si
vous voulez et cetera les choses ne sont
pas tout puisque le service est
obligatoire si le service mais qu'est ce
que je fais comment je dois réagir
jean-marie pertuis si vous n'êtes pas
satisfait des émissions de la télévision
est ce que pour vous dispenser pourtant
de payer la redevance investi la même
chose bien qu'on soit pas satisfait du
service vous êtes en rentrant et en
commandant vous avez passé un contrat
aux termes de ce contrat vous engagez à
payer la consommation aux débutants et
habiller le service à la personne qui
joue c'est toujours en marche
[Musique]
en principe la route a fait
240 250 francs pour deux personnes et au
bar uniquement à la terrasse d'un café
ou au restaurant vous pouvez tous
rencontrés le service est de 10 12 15 ou
même 20 % en sus compris ou non un seul
conseil bien lire les écriteaux
concernant le service un rappel le
pourboire n'est jamais obligatoire
moi je vis des 15% que chacun de mes
clients dont le patron donne rien ici
je n'ai pas c'est notre salaire qui est
répartie dans l'ensemble du personnel
selon la catégorie en plus il encore en
plus des catégories qui rentre dans
l'hôtellerie selon la catégorie
d'individus il aura il ya une
classification qui était par points vous
avez le 2 michel d'euros qui touche deux
points le premier chef de la chef de
rang qui va toucher trois points et
quand ils et d'anciens dans la mesure où
matches et quatre points dans d'autres
maisons ce sera une autre une autre
foule un autre système pour le paiement
pour la répartition des services
c'est comme ça mais dites moi s'il n'ya
pas par exemple si s'il n'y a pas de
clients à un moment bien précis de
l'année le bac vous crever de faim je
crève de faim saison voudra v2 faisons
face à lire ici on n'a pas la saison
c'est toute l'année qu'il n'y a pas de
ya pas de saison chez nous certes
certains certains camarades qui
travaillent dans d'autres endroits ont
des petits restaurants que je rencontre
ils ont rien gagné le mini votre ferr
oreilles est salariée ou pas si par
exemple on disait en supprime le service
non parce que lorsqu'on plus en plus
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
vient s'ajouter à cela ce qu'on appelle
nous le petit trot
le citron c'est pour voir voilà c'est ça
fait quand même une somme importante sur
la finale l'oracle ça finit par faire
des sommes importantes
bon alors en gros vous veniez combien
par mois
alors seulement chez c'est énorme la cc
non je gagne très bien ma vie c'est tout
et alors dites-moi quand il ya de très
bons restaurants avec de remarquables
pour bois oui il doit pas y avoir
beaucoup de place ça ça se revend des
plus maintenant plus maintenant on
achetait le tablier on a combien ça le
montant des sommes fabuleuses acheter un
thème les jeter le tablier à montpellier
1 500 milles mais à cette époque là je
parle de ça il ya quinze ans c'est pas
très moral mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses qui nous ont bon moral il ya
beaucoup d'autres choses vous prenez
toutes et tous les bureaux de placement
tous les bureaux de placement pour
l'hôtellerie qui demande qui demande à
petit une petite prime annuelle vous
savez alors si vous allongez un petit
peu la prime on vous donne des bonnes
places
si vous donnez pas une tune on vous file
rien du tout c'est pour voir partout
quoi c'est le convoi parti national a
exactement seulement
certainement c'est un monsieur d'un
certain âge est un site
oui j'en suis certaine
et
merci monsieur
[Musique]
monsieur oublie pas de service s'il vous
plaît allez monsieur ça fait partie de
la bonne tenue de la maison bastien
mais si vous êtes vous venez donnez
combien les jeunes et les empêcher de
cotation mais j'ai autre chose qu est-ce
qu on les voit et je pense monnaies jeu
je fais que mon collègue l'avouer qu'est
ce que vous allez d'un québécois je
viens de donner un mois je peux pas
payer tout sur tout tout le temps on
verrait si j'avais partie du commerce
précisant ça monsieur
moi je crois que l'on avait à boire bis
et excusez moi l'expression ça reste que
vous devenez vous tout le monde était
comme ça mais ma foi ce moment là moi je
donne ma démission je ne peux pas rester
vous faites combien par jour à peu près
donc je fais à peu près lost art of
death pierre uniquement toilettes je
fais dans les 43
merci monsieur je n'ai pas de salaire je
suis à la merci du client donc si
ses propres si c'est bien entretenu le
client a la gentillesse de me laisser un
service c'est pas trop ça c'est ton
talent il pas surveillé jacques billant
sinon ça deviendrait impossible garder
les gens sont anxieux une kermesse à la
chasse d'eau elle est tirée tiré là je
peux la direccte
saint gobain vieux vêtements ancien
général et sai les trois pères du bignon
ceux qui sont seuls savent rien du tout
pour les services à l'échelle de france
à se passer la même chose
les papiers sont par terre les vidéos
sont pas faire les tubes de rouge à
lèvres sont oubliés sur les lavabos
c'est une véritable sinécure de travail
oui oui bon c'est l'eau coule l'eau
voilà le robinet n'est pas fermée alors
fermez le voile a donné un petit coup de
barre est tout à fait à chaque fois que
je peux maîtriser quelqu'un qui passe
avait là rien donné mais ça m'étonne pas
je suis pas mon poste donc il donnera
rien alors moi je trouve ça a dit la
messe et ses fresques pourquoi faites
vous ce métier parce qu'il vous rapporte
je le fais parce que d'abord j'aime le
contact du public c'est un métier repas
dansant dans ce sens nous pas est-ce
qu'à d'autres endroits doit pas pas
d'autres endroits plus plus intéressant
plus sympathique pour être en contact
avec la clientèle
oui il faut trouver mais en principe ces
hôpitaux
[Musique]
cet accès
le jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entendu hier ils vont vous laisser du
tour barda pago j'espère promis on vous
donne là on voudra prendre vous aviez
combien l'affiché
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voyons ça fait
c'est bien pour vous c'est un pourboire
normale normale des pauvres contre les
pouvoirs concours puisque j'ai donné les
devants 6 7% alors un oui oui quand on
regarde on est gentil mais c'est normal
donc cette gentille et que ce monsieur
est pas si gentil ça tel monsieur gentil
avec moi je avec ses bons alors merci
d'un service est évidemment parce qu'une
agréable parce que j'ai été rapide
et puis alors il va bien sûr ça vous
embête pas des cellules pourboire non
pas celui que je suis était gentil ça
veut dire quoi gentillesse va il vous a
tendu où on a voulu c'est tout sauf une
somme de combien dangereux ces trois là
qui vous savez c'est très variable c'est
en fonction de ça dépend des clients ça
y est les clients qu'il est si les
clients qui les sports je peux pas vous
dire des points on atteint 15 francs
puis à rien de fixer la réponse d'un
service c'est pour voir ça correspond à
quoi exactement
disons que ce que vous sentez une
personne qui voulait pour boire une
personne qui ne va pas vous en donner
disons que je m'arrange pas avoir dit
pourquoi
avec un sourire avec quelques mots
gentils vampires des bagages des
tranches de vie dans le coffre
je m'occupais client combien faut donner
de pouvoirs à bas prix la question
discret non pas c'est pas un discret
c'est moi qui le vend des séries t elle
maintenant c'est pas une obligation
c'est paul obligations il ya tant de
l'esprit de noël ou pas non non non non
excusez moi ou quoi pourquoi n'ont ils
disent un sérieux si j'en donne pas bleu
et même si je fais la gueule vous
partirez vous avez rien à [ __ ] et
d'aller voir votre billet quelques jours
nous on est d'accord pour nous de les
stimuler savoyarde 6 57 et 3 10 déjà les
laisse de france et bien c'est bien
aussi ça y est on a quoi vous mettez
votre macbook par derrière parce que
c'est comme ça j'ai un ami tout cas son
coin corrige de la faire ça ça m'emmerde
d'accord voilà derrière
et lorsque le client est un étranger
cette france
le service le 8 francs
ok
mais ça y est les prix
un franc 1 franc vrai c'est jusqu'au
bout donner encore si vous voulez ah bah
si vous voulez mais pas si vous prenez
combien sont passives ou présentement 10
15% ça dépend de la somme aux français
on le propose deux fils nés aux
étrangers on le prend d'office parce que
quitte à ne rien reprenez car comme je
suis étranger vous n'allez pas alors
j'ai pris dispensable donné d'ailleurs
je vous apprends bien c'est marqué sur
les bulletins toiture il est d'usagé de
donner un pourboire aux conducteurs mais
celui ci ne peut l'exigé bon vous me
demandez je vous dis bah en moyenne ces
dix pour cent mais il n'est que
facultatif n'est pas obligatoire
une suite d'attentes devant un cinéma
peut-être une pièce pour le chanteur qui
nous a fait patienter en musique
[Musique]
moi je la ferai toujours pourquoi
par habitude
elle vous rend un service 7 ouvreuse des
fois est-ce que d'après vous c'est un
pur beurre uniquement ou c'est un
salaire complet pour moi c'est un
pourboire très bien parce qu'on va
passer derrière
est-ce que vous allez donner de l'argent
à l'heureuse oui combien
pourquoi c'est l'habitude ce sens
humiliant c'est désagréable de donner de
l'argent à une personne c'est
désagréable devrait avoir un salaire
alors expliquez-moi comment êtes vous
payez vous heureusement pour uniquement
l'aspect gens sont généreux ça dépend du
du film sur tout et quand ça varie selon
le film
en moyenne nous avons fait la moyenne
mais la moyenne ne varie pas entre varie
entre 45 centimes et 50 centimes par
client non mais un train ter quand on a
des groupes il ya un front pour 10
personnes que les gens soir 2 3 4 5
le probant ne varie pas toujours un
franc c'est l'éternelle quête d'un fonds
qui revient généralement les sur le
billet
comme je vais devant je donnais un franc
et puis je continue tous âges c'est ça
plutôt que pour être remplacés oui et on
veut
vous allez donner en francs l'hérault
pour moi puisque comme vous l'avez
d'extérieur de la pas de salaire ce
n'est alors si vous vous donnez un
salaire vous pouviez insuffisant en
france en multipliant le nombre
d'entrées regardez là que je pense que
ça fait pas marine pour cette séance
à moyen terme c'est bien parce qu'on dit
que les ouvreuses se font des salaires
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu une émission à
la radio qui nous a énormément
d'ailleurs des plus il ya eu nombreuse
qui a dit qu'elle gagnait 1 million par
mois ce qui est absolument faux et se
répondent et peut-être du cinéma alors
il n'y a aucune salle on gagne un
million par mois
c'est absolument impossible et moi tu
m'aimes pas même pas la loi ni quoi et
si on gagne pas le smig pendant trois
mois qu'on nous l'on nous donne le
complément c'est vraiment le formulaire
en dessous de 6000 sinon nous donne rien
la direction donne absolument rien
vraiment rien voilà
au caramel chocolat
ou pourboire s'ajouteront les 5% de la
confiserie vendus elles sont cinq
ouvreuse dans cette salle elles auront
1% chacune
ça représente deux séances apprend du
ragoût ne gagne pas d'argent
et oui mais faut pas oublier qu'on va
devoir partager ça en 5 ce soir hilda
combien la peu près 60 francs 60 francs
de séance voilà mon cas d'hier vous avez
gagné combien y'a bien normalement je
devrais pas le dire mais enfin à faire
voilà entre nous
ferrante 40 francs qui en feront pas
rose alors votre salaire mensuel à peu
près bien et enfin entre 1800 et 2000
alors on va venir entre 1800 et 2000 5
mai 2005 ça qu'on fait une fois dans
l'année quoi il faut il faut faire une
moyenne
est ce que vous allez donner un
pourboire à l'ouvreuse
c'est rentré dans les moeurs je crois
que c'est tout à fait normal selon l'ena
pour voir aussi à votre coiffeur sans
doute non je me sais ma femme qui me
coiffe juger de tout pour moi je
m'appelle henri leroy de l'exemple ça me
donne le frisson et quand je fais des
francs
chez les doigts qui me démange qui les
critiquent ce milan
marianne vous êtes shampouineuse
consiste en championnat
vous avez un salaire et un pourboire et
des pourboires
il est pour boire alors vous pouvez
parler de l'un à l'autre
qu'est ce qui fait l'intérêt de la place
ici pour voir pourquoi vie sur nous pour
voir ici même dans le métier de coiffure
est ce que vous pouvez dire une bonne
journée quand l'assistante combien sa
présence en france indépendamment de
votre salaire c'est laissé à
l'appréciation de la cliente
c'est ça l'art c'est à dire que pour
boire pour un client ça peut être bien 5
francs et 10 francs 10 francs je pense
pas vous n'êtes pas obligé non plus de
la donner et salaires est important le
smi je soumets marilyn et l'assistante
de marque c'est à lui que revient
l'honneur de couper les cheveux de ces
messieurs
je n'ai pas de salaire je suis payé aux
clients chat pourcentage sur les clients
un plus vous faites de clients mieux
voilà c'est évident alors j'ai tort de
donner un nom il ya des clients qui peut
vous donner 15 francs y en a d'autres
qui peuvent très bien dire que c'est
assez cher il parle comme ça puisque le
pouvoir n'est que facultatif marque
entre nous il faut mieux être coiffeur
pour des bourgeois que de coiffer les
ouvriers ce plan financier c'est évident
je m'en serais douté
pourquoi bien parce que premièrement
sont les gens qui sont déjà sont plus
raffinés
non c'est parce qu'ils ont le moyen les
moyens de se faire autre chose qu'une
coupe dont le prix est fixé par le
ministre des finances c'est vrai ça fait
pas du travail à la chaîne et du travail
est plus rentable
aubervilliers la banlieue ouvrière de
paris un salon de catégorie à
c'est-à-dire de première classe
monsieur qu'est ce que ça veut dire prix
raisonnable bien disons que ça veut dire
que les prises sont d'une sont très
honnêtes et représente une certaine
qualité de travail mais dans un quartier
qui qui ne permet pas de faire des prix
est raisonnable
c'est à dire des prix en catégorie à une
coupe normal ça monte à combien une
coupe marne la normale montage francs
c'est à dire le prix de la catégorie à
c'est ça est ce que les gens voulaient
ce du pouvoir en général
énormément ça reflète toujours le
pourboire reflète toujours là une
certaine qualité de travail une certaine
sélection de la clientèle on va demander
à votre client là j'ai mes deux fils
avec quoi jouent les chefs peu près 400
enfants 4 france pour trois personnes
est-ce que là où c'est un bon pour voir
ses impôts voire normal même si
d'ailleurs si je pouvais faire plus je
n'aurai plus pourquoi faire
aubervilliers c'est pas votre projet je
n'aimerais surtout palander je préférais
faire autre chose mais là vous aviez
comme comme projet d'arriver jusqu'aux
sancourt champs elysées c'est la
consécration ici pour vous non
certainement mais ça s'est fait par
chance aussi voilà surtout par chance et
est votre niveau de vie est élevé grâce
à ça et en russie comment
donner
la plupart des salons augmentent leurs
tarifs des 15% de service qui était
jadis le pourboire du garçon coiffeur la
somme à payer donc un prix net et
pourtant il est d usage
valais c'est tout
je remarque est toujours rage est
impossible pour tout le monde moins
chaud c'est un peu gênant comme un peu
humiliant l'enfant
merci monsieur normalement c'est par ici
voilà encore c'est toujours j'ai
toujours lundi leur souplesse
vous avez des connaissances et votre
enfant
je tiens compte du service est évident
que si on est comme mon pare-brise
2 si on a un petit soit je suis attentif
et c'est normal de jonah pourquoi et on
va regarder alors hein
mais pareil parce qu'ils salah
arpu est simple on va vous donner une
somme importante
les pare brise
à d'autres endroits il a combien cela on
saluera je pense que je vais être assez
généreux parce que je revienne belgique
et en belgique on vous nettoie jamais le
pare-brise a donc en belgique vous ne
donnez jamais de pourboires
non ça fait au moins à oui oui toute
façon la chine
pour éviter entre autres le geste du
pourboire des stations-service self
service sont ouvertes depuis quelques
années en france
s'il n'y a pas de problème de la
bourriche pourquoi passer ça me débecte
c'est mendicité ça m'avait été donnée un
mec qui faisait la manche et puis il
avait parlé de faire la manche
l'importance à lyon nice et son salaire
est ce que ça vous gêne pas trop de même
anoh vous préférez ça plutôt qu un
pompiste fonctionne pas c'est pas trop
craintives c'est plus rapide
ça veut dire des impôts - abandonniez
quand même lorsque vous alliez dans une
pente normale très rarement pendant que
faisait mon pare-brise
monsieur schefer est ce rentable tout ça
oui certainement pourquoi c'est rentable
pour les raisons suivantes c'est que
dans les heures de pointe un peu comme
vous voyez actuellement
en ce moment il faudrait quand même au
moins 6 5 à 6 pompiste pour assurer le
service
alors là une caissière seul peut arriver
à satisfaire les demandes
là maintenant il peine s'ils veulent et
ils prennent le maximum neuf fois sur
dix parce que comme il s'essaie visant
je sais pas s'ils en font un jeu ou pas
enfin il se savait en pleine
certainement beaucoup plus peut-être que
si un pont qui savent avait proposé un
plein
un pourboire la halle ont ils fait les
obsèques on va leur demander alors
demandé pourquoi vous n'avez pas laisser
pour voir pourquoi
quoi qu'en rassemblant au bas de 12 ans
je remercie les sens et pas cherché par
balles par à lui dire
voilà
le savoir il ne vous a pas créé pour
voir parce qu'il prouve que les ans est
assez cher maintenant il ne trouve
jamais qu son pare brise est trop propre
il aurait pu lui dire non c'est pas la
peine
sachant qu'il n'avait pas vous donner de
la voix
unia les clients comme s'ils nous disent
non c'est pas la peine du service non
fait mon pare-brise moi même je reprends
gestion des services
les gens de pouvoir nous mêmes ici le
réflexe pour boire et elle qui à défaut
de service le récompense le sourire de
la caissière
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur roger la porno ou
éditeur oui ça c'est mes tâches gauche
insensé
merci
mais pour moi moi je suis pour donner un
pourboire tout ça sera pour moi car j'ai
tout donné qui bat au petit
télégraphiste on au postier n'importe
qui oui moi chez le coiffeur aussi alors
oui pourquoi surtout parce qu'elle va
bien ça signifie quoi
ça c'est de donner pouvoir bah moi je
travaille pour avoir le gros boire
j'estime que tout le monde verra
je suis concierge et bien je gagne pas
beaucoup alors quand on me donne un peu
moins sous le manteau on dit des fois
que les et prennent des concierges
atteignent des sommes astronomiques aux
dépens ça dépend où
mais en prenant votre cas ah bah moi je
vais pas me plaindre ce sont tous des
gens bien gras la maison est en fait
mais bien les proposent oui mais
récompensés de quoi alors que les
services que vous l'entendez habana
porte pas candidat prend tous les
services possibles
alors si je ne vous donne rien afin
d'aller comment vous réagissez pareil
moi le petit gars qui ont sixième dans
une chambre 7e et qui me donne mille
francs s'il ya but ou d'autres qui
rentraient quand même ces colis et
recommandés mais on dit que pour être
bien avec sa concierge
il faut quand même lui donner une pièce
de temps en temps un petit la catalane à
dos en fin d'année un beau cadeau c'est
ça des ports et les petits étudiants et
une tonne un petit bouquet de fleurs à
la fin de l'année ça me suffit pourtant
pas bonjour je suis chez mademoiselle à
soleil
[Musique]
on est en train de vous filmer pour fr3
édition vendredi
vous n'allez pas pouvoir c'est pas une
habitude pour vous donner pendant qu'on
se demande pourquoi pourquoi je ne peux
en voir je sais pas c'est pas un métier
mais je sais pas
oui payé payé par les cultes et évoquant
son métier je peux l'essayer 120 dates
pour les bonbons et ça dépend comment
fonctionne la rémunération d'employés
parce que mon silence fixe normale et où
on compte pas le fait qu'il va avoir des
pourboires n'y a pas de problème mais
par exemple un garagiste un ouvrier ils
réagissent à lapentti commence à
travailler plupart du temps ils sont
parce que pas à payer quand ils
apprennent à être mais qu à nouveau des
trucs comme ça et il compte toujours sur
le pouvoir du client pour allonger la
source et le patron du garage donne
toujours dit toujours vous aurez les
pouvoirs ou le pompiste
on compte toujours que la sauce sera
allongée par le pourboire du gars qui en
a rendu toyer le pare brise en deux
je sais pas c'est l'apprenti qui
travaille chez un gars comme ça moi je
suis contre parce qu'ils comptent ils
comptent sur le client pour allonger la
sauce de la paye qui veut pas donner
alors parce que vous êtes contre vous ne
donnez pas pour boire ça dépend et les
faut on sent complètement obligés en
plus on est coincé par par un quartier
par des habitudes par les commerçants
par des trucs comme ça la lorraine ma
guise dans les maquis ce temps enfin
encore la main qui ce temps c'est
tellement déplaisant qu'on arrive
toujours à s'en sortir mais quand c'est
tellement plus tacite et moi je t'ai
vendeuse
on m'a donné un pouvoir parce que
j'avais fait un paquet de cadeau j'ai
refusé parce que les gens parlent de
l'ain pour voir ce que je fais mon
métier vous avez déjà eu un très gros
chèque en fin d'année en cas de oui oui
j'ai vu mon chèque peut pas dire à
profit ce que vous en faites pas cent
mille francs mille francs pas mais ça
fait déjà une bonne soeur c'est
intéressant
si la chanson
bah oui je le dis
madame savez vous que dans certains
immeubles parisiens les concierges se
font des étrennes qui aborde le milieu
haut de sa veste non ça j'alignerai
alors qu'est ce qui se passe ici dans
une cité au toute façon on est loin de
toucher un million 1
on touche des étrennes c'était
évidemment d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait
que beaucoup de gardiens concerne
l'emploi de gardiens parce que s'il n'y
avait pas des prêts mais de pourboire
proprement dite ce salaire en vaudrait
pas la peine puisque nous avons même pas
le smig et c'est les gens vous remercie
selon ce qu'ils jugent vous avez fait ou
pas fait votre travail même des fois
vous avez fait pour ça que vous en dogme
enfin à moins que vous ayez eu une
altercation particulière avec eux alors
là les et red bull en est point question
ça varie entre combien et combien la
somme ça dépend de la gardienne alors et
vous prenez votre cas bah ça dépend ça
doit faire 1500 francs 150 mille francs
pour combien de locataires pour 130 du
lac à terme et en face ça varie assez de
1500 à 2000 francs quand même il ya des
gens à qui on a rendu quand même dans
des années de très grands services et
qui ont su compenser ses services par de
parler pour moi même des fois très
nombreux alors madame savez vous que
dans dans certaines loges parisienne on
paierait on paierait une somme
importante pour devenir concierge ces
formats qui paieraient pour devenir
conseillère j'avoue que je gagnerais
trois fois plus je cesse mes activités à
la fin du mois et croyez moi que jamais
jeunes heures je ne recommencerai ce
genre de travail
alors c'est trop vous et trois à la
merci des gens et puis c'est trop même
pour un pourboire vous savez il ya des
services qui seront très difficiles à
rendre
à votre bon coeur messieurs hamer encore
monsieur tous ces gens
mais ce
messieurs
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
bonjour 157 bas madame non maintenant
évidemment même si je n'aime pas ma
tasse les festivals à venir finir dans
les marais vous donner une pièce à ce
monsieur
parce qu'il est gentil nous appartenons
tous à domicile
et s'il doit revenir et reviennent ainsi
à personne y revient dirai à personne
c'est beau non merci alors voyez ici
pour le remercier et de même très gentil
dont vous connaissez donc oui ça fait
déjà un moment
voilà mesdames
[Applaudissements]
les gens sont choqués il ya deux
s'achète composition chouette parce que
ça vous donne rien au départ il fait
très attention au contraire contre en
jambes a jamais de saladin sarita bulle
et je me sens pas obligé de venir
il bâtit madame
il ya même en avons gagné combien de
pourvoir allez on va lui faire sentir
en gros en gros pour moi au 320 330 oui
alors s'arrondit bien ça le plaisir
vient ça correspond à quest pourboire
pour google bon je vous avez été un peu
d'habitude a de tout temps
non content de donner du pourboire à
chaque instant le français qui
décidément généreux se créent de
nouvelles habitudes
il récompense le commerçant qui a la
gentillesse de lui vendre sa marchandise
oui la plupart du temps ça veut dire
quoi c'est pas c'est une marque de
sympathie non on sait désormais mieux ou
bien non je sais pas si tu domines et
monsieur bourse avaient souvent nous on
voit ça arrive de temps en temps ça
représente quoi comme la dame diane
jeunes marques de sympathie pour poster
sciemment pour être mieux servis mais
enfin une gratitude quoi à la rentrée
voila voila nous donner un pourboire
pourquoi parceque il d'être assez mal et
puis je suis très bien servis si les
données combien vous êtes curieux
oui oui vous avez des containers franc
ça n'augmente pas trop le prix donné moi
parce que
cette maison me rends service j'habite
au 6ème étage du téléphone de chez moi
et on n'y prend pas garde
le service y compris la même
alors qu'est ce que je fais en principe
parce que j'ai pas l'habitude c'est la
première fois que je me fais livrer
beaucoup oui je fais un chèque mais je
veux dire pour pour le service commence
à se donner un peu je vous le mets
pichelot chute
oui et je laisse combien un petit cours
en principe on laisse combien là pour
louer un gîte 148 francs là qu'est ce
que je dois vous laisser pour ça soit
bien pour ça soit correcte par shine
france 5 france et bien les gens sont
généreux en général je vis à quelques
jeunes qui veulent faire le boulot alors
avant le boulot de livreur à et au moins
d'un village par la roquette
tous les vélos les plus libres et qui
perturbe le plus avant et pourquoi pas
ce que parce qu'on donne plus de
pourboire sait pour quelles raisons
ben c'est à dire elle est jolie gueule
pendant une visite à messaâd et les
quêtes diversification regardez moi même
camion comme vous me placer la nièvre et
1 1 au niveau des pourboires comment ça
se passe en général ça se passe bien les
gens sont généreux voit quand même vous
donner 5 francs oui vous allez faire
combien de clients dans la journée au
tchad et pain est aujourd'hui j'affirme
en amont que septième ah ben ça alors
c'est impossible de rouler impossible on
les ya dix jours ça va aller où ça va
pas soigner jamais la maison jacques
elle nous donne on savait qu'à lui
chaque fois par mois adacore donc est à
l'arrêt
vous savez que certains certains
bouchers se font jusqu'à 8000 francs
pour avoir compris hélas oui oui un
certaines maisons comme dans les grandes
surfaces de boucherie berner par exemple
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
monsieur bora tiers ont dit que vos
bouchées se font des sommes
astronomiques en pourboires monsieur
je pense que c'est faux et ce problème
est pour nous d'une grande ambiguïté
vous n'avez pas été sans remarquer en
rentrant dans ce magasin nous avions
apposé une affiche concernant le pouvoir
et celle ci et qui dit très précisément
le pourboire est interdite les clients
victimes de sollicitations ou mal servis
sont invités à se faire connaître
nous effectuons une surveillance
discrète sur un client qui est en
service a donné une gratification à son
vendeur nous approchons de lui et nous
lui disons nous consomma dame au
monsieur qui n'était pas indispensable
de donner un pot doit pouvoir aussi
modeste soit-il à votre garçon pour être
bien servi et le client nous répond
monsieur il n'y a aucun texte de loi qui
m'empêche de gratifier votre garçon qui
m'a apporté un service si j'estime que
ce garçon a effectué son travail
correctement et que je veux le
récompenser est-ce que vous avez laissé
du pouvoir le toucher
allez avouez oui quel 55
c'est pourquoi c'est interdit je sais
alors pourquoi quand vous avez fait pour
lui donner à mener d'ici dans les petits
papiers comme tout le monde c'est
d'ailleurs comme tout mon père oui c'est
pas bien servi c'est interdit
c'est super bien servi dès qu'on va
toujours vers le même boucher estime que
la viande est un produit en soi déjà
suffisamment cher et que les gens ou les
clients n'ont pas sonné un pouvoir pour
être servi d'où la sanction
comment ça se passe là vous avez là les
tombes de la ceinture ou fait expliquer
mon film est carrément contre ça mais
vous vous pointez la pièce avec votre
nom n'ont même pas comme ça mais
pourquoi donner vous justement cette
pièce papa sow c'est normal c'est normal
moi je trouve ça normal
mais c'est pour être bien sûr week-end
n'ont pas spécialement pour prendre un
taxi vous donner pour boire
si l'âge
sentant les exceptions existent pourtant
à paris par exemple le théâtre de la
ville sa devise le sourire qui vous
accueillent ici n'attend que le vôtre en
échange ça règle le pourboire interdit
ici l'ouvreuse est une employée comme
une autre
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce système
est ce que les gens des fois vous donne
un pourboire
ça arrive qu'ils nous en propose en fait
nous nous refusons puisque ce n'est pas
acceptée hôtel mais quel est votre
travail à regarder les gens passer vous
leur faites rien là pas du tout nous
indique à quel rang ça se passe j'ai
tout chanter man o'war vous êtes pour le
personnage qu'on doit payer normalement
les gens je trouve c'est très agréable
d'entrer dans un théâtre sans avoir
toujours de l'argent dans les poches à
distribuer à droite à gauche
insupportable au restaurant aussi le
pourboire est interdite les serveuses
son pays aux 15% la chine plus de calcul
pour les clientèles les prix sont en net
le pourboire est strictement interdite
sous peine de renvoi du personnel cette
année avec les femmes je n'ai pas eu de
renvoi de personnel avec les hommes
j'avais des difficultés
je m'excuse mais
alors si je suis client je suis content
je laisse quand même une pièce par
habitude qu'est ce que vous faites
à
si je ne la vois pas je ne peux rien
dire mettez dans votre poche apa - enfin
le server le serveur si le client
forcément paraît qu'il a laissé une
pièce il va pas pour et après forcément
pour lui renvoie sa pièce mais en
général et fait attention car cet impôt
de renvoi immédiat pour voir interdit je
trouve ça tout à fait normal
j'estime que le cours voire doit être
compris dans dans le prix c'est à dire
que le patron doit payer ses employés au
même titre que n'importe quel employé
travail oit la sncf n'y a aucune raison
que le le
le titre sera habillé n'est pas un
pourboire pour vous avoir bien servi
est ce que le service ne s'en ressent
par est-ce que vous avez bien été servis
l'un très bien que nous sommes nous
venons régulièrement très souvent
monsieur là bas a dit monsieur joffrin
problème d'ailleurs pour moi c'est une
règle d'or tout le restaurant lequel on
va on préfère le service tout compris
des prix n'est tout compris en service
boissons ce drame n'y ait pas de sous et
c'est aussi bien pour nous que pour le
hôteliers qui travaillent et y compris
pour le personnel parce que le personnel
c'est là c'est la mendicité donc il ya
pas de raison qu ils s'abaissent sept
mandats savoir quelles conditions de
travail et être sûrs de leur salaire ni
d'être la seule en europe à nation
dignité un dernier détail monsieur
lorsque vous prenez de l'essence ou
lorsque vous allez chez m parfois on
lorsque vous allez au cinéma
premièrement je vais toujours en des
pompes avec les réductions première
premier face et deuxièmement le
pourboire pas du tout jamais de pouvoir
jamais pour moi c'est sûr qu'il veut ou
bien les cheveux tout à fait d'ailleurs
je vais toucher le maire
un copain avec les gg aucune fleur n'ai
eu aucune mais aucune récrimination
alors peut-on parler de solutions
futuriste le prix net
ah oui il faut abolir le pourboire
on me dit qu'on s'en tape tout à fait
contre la main à la poche fini les sens
le coiffeur pourtant en nombre
on a fini pas toujours la mendicité non
je suis content
[Musique]